1998 IN LATE APRIL AGAINST THE
BULLS.
STEVE KERR WAS ON THAT TEAM, AND
ON THAT BULLS' TEAM, AND A VERY
LITTLE FANFARE ABOUT THAT ONE TO
MUCH DIFFERENT STORY NOW.
>> Reggie: I CAN'T EVEN
REMEMBER --
>> Brian: CURRY LETTING IT FLY,
AND THERE IT IS.
RIGHTWAY.
HE HAS TIED RAY ALLEN AND ONE
DOWN AND ONE TO GO.
>> Reggie: IT IS GOING TO HAPPEN
FAST, RIGHT?
THE BUZZ IN THE BUILDING IS
INCREDIBLE.
AND TO HAVE THE GUY WHO REALLY
TOOK THE RECORD FROM ME,
BETWEEN DRAYMOND GREEN AND
STEPH.
>> Brian: WIGGINS INSIDE IS
FOULED.
A CHANCE TO CATCH OUR BREATH AS
WIGGINS IS GOING TO HAVE A
CHANCE TO GO TO LINE, AND THE
TYING THREE, AND THE ALL-TIME
RECORD, AND STEPHEN CURRY KNOWS
ONE MORE TO GO TO STAND ALONE.
>> Reggie: LOOK, I HAD SOME GAME
SEVENS IN THIS BUILDING AND I
WAS NOT THIS NERVOUS.
THIS IS UNSOME UNBELIEVABLE
ATMOSPHERE GOING ON HERE.
YOU HAVE FANS CONTINUING TO
STAND THROUGH A FREE THROW.
>> Brian: REGGIE, YOU HELD THE
RECORD FOR 13 YEARS AND STEVE
KERR WAS ON THE BROADCAST WITH
>> Reggie: AND AS EVERYONE
STANDS UP IN UNISON NOW AS MR.
CURRY BRINGS THE BALL UP ONCE
AGAIN.
>> Brian: ALEC BURKS GUARDING IT
FROM THE START, AND WIGGINS
AGAIN, AND HERE IS CURRY FOR THE
RECORD, AND IT IS GOOD.
THERE IT IS!
STEPHEN CURRY, THE ALL-TIME
THREE-POINT KING OF THE NBA!
THREE-POINTER NUMBER 2,974, THE
MAN WHO CHANGED THE GAME, AND
THE IGNITER OF THE THREE-POINT
REVOLUTION OF THE NBA AND NOW HE
STANDS ALONE AT THE TOP OF THE
THREE-POINT LIST.
>> Reggie: YOU THINK ABOUT IT,
AND THE WAY HE CHANGED THE GAME,
AND IT IS ALMOST LIKE THE WAY
THAT BABE RUTH CHANGED BASEBALL
WITH THE LONG BALL, AND HE HAS
CHANGED THE GAME WITH THE
THREE-POINT BALL, AND HOW ALL 30
TEAMS APPROACHED THE GAME IS
BECAUSE OF NUMBER 30.
AND THIS IS AN ABSOLUTE AWESOME
EXPERIENCE TO BE ABLE TO
WITNESS, TO SEE RAY ALLEN AND
NOW STEPHEN CURRY AND AN
EMOTIONAL HUG HERE WITH HIS
FATHER DELL CURRY.
>> Brian: YOU SAW DELL AND HIS
MOTHER SONIA, AND BOB McKILLIP
HIS HIGH SCHOOL COACH, AND HIS
HEAD COACH AT DAVIDSON AND THE
MAN NEXT TO HIM IS DAVID RILEY
WHO IS THE MAN WHO DRAFTED CURRY
AS A MEMBER OF THE GOLDEN STATE
WARRIORS AND WHAT A MOMENT THIS
MUST BE.
>> Reggie: AND THE DEGREE OF
DIFFICULTY, RIGHT?
IT DOESN'T MATTER IF YOU HAVE
ONE, TWO, THREE GUYS ON HIM, AND
ALEC BURK CLOSING QUICKLY, AND
LONG THREE AS CURRY HOLDS THE
RECORD.
THERE IS SONIA, HIS MOTHER, IN
ATTENDANCE AS WELL.
QUICK RELEASE.
NOTHING BUT THE BOTTOM.
>> Brian: WHAT A MOMENT.
HERE IT COMES.
AN EMBRACE WITH RAY ALLEN.
RAY ALLEN BROKE REGGIE MILLER'S
RECORD ON FEBRUARY 10th, AND NOW
STEPHEN CURRY BREAKS RAY ALLEN'S
RECORD, TUESDAY, DECEMBER 14th,
AT MADISON SQUARE GARDEN A
28-FOOTER, AND STEPHEN CURRY,
THE ALL-TIME THREE-POINT SHOOTER
IN THE NBA.